- When did you start acting?
You're pretty young.
- Yeah.
When did I start acting?
Well, I started awhile ago.
I think I started when
I was like eight, nine.
I took some classes at Strasbourg.
- That's early.
- Yeah.
- What made you wanna do acting?
- I don't know.
(everyone laughs)
- Oh my god, I love you.
- It was my-
- You're like, "It was a
Tuesday, I saw pamphlet."
(Kelly laughs)
- My stepfather...
He's a lawyer, but he
really loves photography,
and he's an amazing photographer.
And when I was like seven he took like
a cinematography class and he had me...
There we are.
- [Kelly] Aww.
- [Sophia] That's great.
- [Michelle] Oh, look at the
little munchkin, coochie coo!
- [Sophia] And he had me drag
that wagon around New York.
- [Kelly] I love your outfit.
- Thank you, thank you.
- Aw dude, that's awesome!
- Yeah it was-
- And your cute haircut with it.
- Yeah, so that happened and (laughs)
(audience laughs)
- So wait, you did this
for him for a class
and then it just kind of stuck?
- Yeah he said he would give me,
allow me to go to McDonald's after.
- Oh my god, so you're my son.
He is the same way.
Anything for those fries.